[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: To get started with
the Cloud Natural Language API
for Python, you need
a GCP project which
you can set up in the console.
In your project, enable
the Google Natural Language
API for that project.
Then create a service account
and download the private key
as JSON.
You use these credentials
to access Google Cloud APIs.
So keep it secure and out of
your code and public repos.
To access the credentials
from your project,
set up an environment variable.
I'm going to use
PyCharm as my ID.
So the way I set up a
variable is different.
I'll show you that shortly.
If you aren't using
PyCharm, go to the terminal
and set an environment variable
to the path of your service
account.
Prepare your environment
for Python development.
Again, I'm using
PyCharm, but you
can use whatever dev
environment you prefer.
If you are using
PyCharm, then under Run,
select Edit Configurations.
In the section
environment, there
is an Environment
Variable field.
Click on this and add the Google
application credentials here.
Next, install the client library
from the terminal, or IDE.
If you use Cloud
Shell in the console,
you can skip this step since
the required dependencies
are already included.
Make a new file or
open an existing file.
Import the Google
Cloud Client Library
and then instantiate a client.
Provide some text to analyze.
I'm going to go with a
classic example here.
Now, create a document
which has a field called
content set to the
text you are analyzing
and a field code type
which, as the name suggests,
is the type of text--
in this case, plain text.
Call analyze_sentiment,
passing the document.
This function returns an
analyze_sentiment response.
analyze_sentiment response has
three properties-- document
sentiment, the overall
sentiment of the input document;
language, the
language of the text;
and sentences, the sentiment
for all the sentences
in the document.
Set the sentiment variable
to the document_sentiment.
Log the parameters of
sentiment score and magnitude.
Score is a sentiment
score between negative 1
for negative sentiment
and positive 1
for positive sentiment.
Magnitude is a number
between 0 and infinity,
which represents the
absolute magnitude
of the sentiment regardless
of positive or negative score.
OK, go ahead and run the code.
And there you go.
You've just sent
your first request
to the Natural Language API.
But there's so much more that
the Cloud Natural Language
API can do, like analyzing
syntax and annotating text.
To find out more about
the client libraries,
consult natural language basics
or work through the sentiment
analysis tutorial and check
out the Cloud documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]